hi i'm vanessa i'm a pastry chef and i
love cheesecake i make it for special
occasions holidays and even if i just
have some extra time i feel like there's
always time for cheesecake so today i'm
gonna teach you how to make a 20-minute
cheesecake a two-hour cheesecake and a
two-day cheesecake so let's get started
first we're gonna make our 20-minute
cheesecake this is perfect for
last-minute dinner plans where you can
make it right before dinner and then
you'll be set right in time for a
dessert i've got some cream cheese here
some sugar and i have a double boiling
pot that way you don't burn your cream
cheese or your sugar while you're
melting it and we're going to give this
just a quick stir just to incorporate
all the ingredients while that's melting
i'm going to bloom my gelatin by adding
the gelatin to some water this is going
to activate the gelatin and i'll i'm
just going to stir my cream cheese and
my sugar get it nice and melted you'll
see the cream cheese start to turn to
more of a off-white that's when you know
that your sugar is melting in with your
cream cheese we're going to add our
lemon juice our vanilla and our lemon
zest the vanilla is really going to
bring the flavor out of the lemon and
then you also want to be able to get
that fresh lemon flavor if you have a
little bit of lumps you can switch from
a spatula into a whisk the best
cheesecakes are nice and smooth have a
nice texture and consistency so now
we've got all of our lumps out
everything's melted and incorporated
we're going to add our gelatin and let
our gelatin melt i'm gonna put this in
the freezer to let it cool off okay so
i've let this chill for about five
minutes now i'm going to add our
store-bought whipped cream and fold it
in in increments you don't want to stir
it because that takes the air out of
your whipped cream so we're just folding
it in
i can definitely smell the lemon zest
you're gonna see the change in color and
you're also gonna see that your mixture
is getting nice and light and airy and
we're going to put it into our prepared
mini pie shells you just want one big
scoop you don't want to mess with it too
much because again you don't want the
air to come out okay so now i'm going to
put these in the freezer for 15 minutes
until they're set and then we'll be
ready to serve i love a little garnish
to really brighten up the cheesecake so
we've got some lemon wedges here
and i'm gonna add some fresh mint i love
the color and it's really gonna liven up
the flavor and there you have it a
perfect lemon cheesecake for any type of
social gathering or just for yourself
it's zesty it's creamy and smooth light
and airy perfect let's have a bite
super light airy fresh zesty all the
best components if you have a little bit
more time i'm going to teach you how to
make a two hour cheesecake
for the two hour cheesecake it's
definitely more traditional something
that most people are used to having it's
got nice creamy texture really thick and
of course we're gonna top it off with
strawberries for a nice presentation for
your guests so the first thing we're
gonna do is have graham cracker crumbs
then we're gonna add our sugar just
enough to sweeten your crust and then
we're gonna add our melted butter give
it a quick stir so everything is nice
and hydrated and incorporated this is
gonna be the crust i love that we have
the pre-prepared graham cracker crumbs
because when i was growing up i used to
have to crunch them by hand and it was
so time consuming so now we're going to
put our graham crackers mixture into our
pie pan you want to add just a little at
a time just because you don't want to
overfill your pan we're going to spread
it out and then you're going to start to
press with your hand all the way up the
sides you want to be firm because you
don't want it to come apart when you're
slicing your cheesecake
alrighty so now we have our prepared
crust pan we're going to put this in the
oven on 350 for five to ten minutes just
so it's nice and firm so now i'm gonna
show you how to make the filling you're
gonna use a stand mixer or you can use a
hand mixer if you have one at home we're
gonna add our cream cheese and we're
gonna mix our cream cheese just for a
second because we want it to get nice
and smooth
then we're gonna add our sour cream this
is gonna really help add flavor and
texture to your cheesecake i'm gonna put
this at a medium speed just so it gets
nice and mixed up
be sure to scrape down the sides of your
bowl while you're mixing to incorporate
all your ingredients and you don't get
any chunks in your cream cheese and
finally i'm going to add the sugar
already now that our cheesecake batter
is nice and smooth we're going to add
the eggs one at a time
you want to make sure you add it one at
a time because you want your eggs to be
fully absorbed and incorporated before
you add the next egg if it doesn't fully
absorb and incorporate then you can get
a really soggy and ill-mixed cheesecake
and no one wants that and of course
vanilla for flavor
now that our cream cheese filling has
been mixed and our crust is set and
baked we're gonna just combine the two
pour right into the pie filling right in
the middle
that looks so good super creamy texture
no lumps i love to see that now we're
gonna put in the oven on 300 for 45
minutes to an hour you want to take it
out when it still has a nice jiggle to
it because it's going to keep cooking as
it cools now we have time to make a
strawberry cheesecake topping so first
you're going to take your strawberries
and you're going to put them in your
skillet you also want to add your sugar
sugar is going to help pull out the
juices of your strawberries we're also
going to add some corn syrup the corn
syrup is going to give it a nice color
and gloss and also some added sweetness
you're going to cook this down you still
want to keep your strawberries intact
we're just making some nice glazed
strawberries
of course you can switch this out to
like blueberries or blackberries or
raspberries but strawberries are the
best we're gonna let them continue
cooking we've got some water here we're
gonna add it to our cornstarch and give
it a nice whisk this is gonna make our
strawberry topping nice and thick so you
can pour it and serve it right on top of
your cheesecake so it should thicken up
fairly quickly you wanna cook your
cornstarch until it gets a nice glossy
color again for about two to three
minutes this looks so good now we're
ready to transfer it into a heatproof
safe bowl we're gonna chill it in the
refrigerator until it's nice and cool
and we'll be ready to top it to our
favorite cheesecake all right so we have
our perfect two hour cheesecake right
here nice and set we let it chill for an
hour so we're just gonna put our
strawberries right on top and we're just
gonna spread it out
this looks so good i love the gloss and
the shine on the strawberries the corn
syrup really helped
and there you have it a two-hour
cheesecake with a lovely strawberry
topping
that is delicious the vanilla and the
strawberry all blends in together it's
got super glassy strawberries a
traditional style cheesecake that
everyone's gonna love stay with me for
our two day cheesecake it's indulgent
decadent and totally worth it
[Music]
the first thing we're gonna do is make
our dark chocolate cookie crust take
your dark chocolate cocoa powder put it
in a bowl then you're going to add your
flour
and your sugar give this just a good mix
just to get it well incorporated we're
going to add a couple of cubes of cold
butter you just want to cut it with your
fork getting it nice and incorporated
you want it to look almost like coarse
sand you're going to add your egg and
you're going to add your vanilla extract
these are the only liquids that you're
going to need to make your dough and it
should come together pretty quickly
you're going to add your pinch of salt
the salt is a flavor enhancer so it's
really going to bring out the flavors of
the vanilla and bring out the flavors of
the chocolate so once it's all
incorporated and it starts to form a
ball be sure to use a little bit of
bench flour to dust onto your table
dump all of your mixture onto the table
and we're just going to knead this for a
few minutes if it starts to get a little
sticky on your table just add just a
little bit more bench flour but you
don't want to add too much because you
can dry out your dough you know that
it's needed enough when everything is
incorporated and you've got a nice soft
ball that isn't too sticky and isn't too
tough we're going to wrap this up and
let it chill in the refrigerator for
about an hour so now it's nice and set i
like to use powdered sugar to dust my
surface because it keeps your dough from
sticking on the surface and also it
keeps it a little sweet too so we're
just gonna roll it out into a nice round
so i'm making it kind of a weird shape
but it'll work just fine you want to
measure this out into an eighth of an
inch we got a three inch cutter we're
gonna cut our rounds you're gonna get
about eight to nine rounds with this
amount of dough for the crust you're
gonna need about seven and i love making
it this size and this thickness because
it cooks faster and more even and you're
able to crumble them up in the food
processor much faster alrighty so we're
going to bake these on 350 for about 15
to 20 minutes and we'll be back okay so
i've got my cookies nice and cool now
we're gonna put them directly into the
food processor give it a nice little
pulse
we're gonna add our powdered sugar give
it a few
pulses we're going to add our melted
butter
and this is going to crumble up really
nicely
so it's nice and incorporated the color
is nice and dark and now we're going to
put it into our spring form pan note
that we put some aluminum foil at the
base of your springform pan because
we're gonna put your pan directly into
your water bath that's gonna help
set your cheesecake and cook it evenly
and just like our two hour cheesecake
we're gonna firmly press it down
on the bottom so now we're gonna chill
this while we create our filling so
we're gonna make our caramel sauce
that's gonna go into our filling and be
a lovely topping to go on top of our
cheesecake we're cooking our sugar on a
medium heat we're gonna get nice and
caramelized you want it to melt fully so
since we're using a dry caramel which
means without water you're gonna want to
stir constantly to evenly distribute the
heat to the sugar so it's getting nice
and liquidy now
and you can see the color is starting to
change it's starting to get to a nice
brown we want it to cook a little darker
cooking the sugar should only take about
three to five minutes total so now there
are a nice dark amber color you're gonna
add your butter we're going to let our
butter melt we're going to add our heavy
cream give it a few stirs let it
incorporate and then in just a moment
you'll have some really glossy caramel
sauce if it gets too hot while you're
incorporating the butter and the heavy
cream go ahead and turn it down to low
or off it should be hot enough for you
to continue melting the butter and the
cream so there you have your caramel
sauce so i'm going to let this cool to
room temperature and then we're going to
make our filling first we're going to
add our cream cheese you want to make
sure that it's nice and mixed up before
you add any other ingredients or it's
going to get really chunky
then you're going to add your sour cream
next we're going to add our sugar
so now we're going to add one at a time
our eggs you want to have that nice
off-white golden color next we're going
to add our vanilla and our white
chocolate you want to make sure that
your white chocolate is melted to room
temperature too hot and it's going to
cook your cheesecake too cold it's going
to seize
i add white chocolate because it really
adds a nice full flavor makes it really
decadent and rich so we're gonna divide
everything into these two bowls we're
gonna put all of the chocolate same as
the white chocolate we melted it at low
power and then we're gonna use only half
a cup of the caramel we're gonna save
the rest to put as a topping then we're
gonna take two cups of the filling and
put it in each of the bowls it's okay if
they're not completely leveled we're
doing this because we're dividing it
into three layers so we have a nice
three layer cheesecake so let's
incorporate the melted chocolate into
the cheesecake
batter and now we're going to stir our
caramel the difference between caramel
and caramel is that caramel is a sauce
caramel is a candy some people use them
a little interchangeably though look at
that pretty color i love this color so
now that looks nice and incorporated
we've got our springform pan and we're
going to layer our filling we're putting
the chocolate in first because it has
the most density and we're going to
smooth this layer out nice and even in
our form pan
now the next two layers you want to make
sure you pour slowly that way it settles
on top and it doesn't zebra in and mix
in with the other layer you can even
kind of
pour it on top in a circular motion
so we're just smoothing it out not to
put too much pressure on the batter and
then finally we're going to add our top
layer which is our white chocolate layer
again you kind of just want to pour it
on top and around and so we're just
going to smooth this out
just so gently now that it's all smooth
i'm going to put this in a water bath
you want a nice pan size that's going to
fit the entire cheesecake
place it into here and then you're going
to get some hot water
and you're gonna pour it
just about
one third to one half of the way up this
helps cook your cheesecake more evenly
and also it's gonna keep it from forming
a dome and cracking so we're gonna put
this in the oven on 300 for about two
hours and then once it's all cooked
through you're gonna put it in the
refrigerator overnight and you need that
full chill all the way through so you
can slice it perfectly and it sets
really nicely okay so now we're gonna
make candy pecans i like to do this on
the first day that way you can get it
out the way let it cool and set ready
for day two and you can put it as your
topping we've got our
water here
we've got our sugar
and we've got some corn syrup
this is on a medium-high heat you don't
want it too hot because you don't want
to cook your sugar too fast you want to
cook your sugar for about three to five
minutes once you get a nice glossy color
you can add your pecans this time you
really want to stir this constantly make
sure you kind of keep them separated so
they don't stick together too much once
your pecans are nice and coated and
glossy we're gonna take
a parchment lined pan and you're just
gonna pour it right on the sheet
be sure to separate your pecans out
while they set take your cheesecake out
of the oven put it in the refrigerator
and then take a nap you deserve it we'll
come back on day two and finish off our
cheesecake
all right so it's day two i've removed
the cheesecake from the foil and the
water bath it's nice and set and you're
just gonna pop it open right from the
bottom it should come right out we have
melted our chocolate and we've also just
reheated our caramel from yesterday
first you're going to drizzle the
chocolate you want to do like a zigzag
and you want to make sure that the
consistency
is liquidy but also thick so it holds
you add your pecans it looks so crunchy
so crispy i'm going to use all of these
there's no such thing as too many pecans
and then once you've chopped it with
your pecans you're going to seal it with
your caramel sauce
this time i like to do it the other way
to give it a nice pattern that looks so
good
[Music]
okay so there you have it you've got
your two-day cheesecake your friends are
gonna be so impressed i'm going to give
myself a very healthy portion look at
the slice that's coming out oh my gosh
so pretty
dig into all these layers
mmm totally
worth it you can totally taste all the
flavors with the white chocolate of the
vanilla the caramel the chocolate the
nice bitter crunchy crust it's so sweet
but it's super balanced that's what i
love about it it's not like an over
sugar block
of cheesecake it really is
a perfect level
of flavor so this was wonderful and
delicious i really hope you enjoyed
making all the different cheesecakes we
made a 20-minute lemon cheesecake a
delicious quick and easy two-hour
strawberry cheesecake and of course the
wonderfully decadent two-day turtle
cheesecake let me know which one was
your favorite in the comments below and
don't forget there's always time for
cheesecake oh yes
[Music]
you